Ladies and gentlemen,
the history of music and television on the Internet
in three minutes.
A TED medley --
a TEDley.
♫ It's nine o' clock on a Saturday ♫
♫ The record store's closed for the night ♫
♫ So I fire up the old iTunes music store ♫
♫ And soon I am feelin' all right ♫
♫ I know Steve Jobs can find me a melody ♫
♫ With one dollar pricing that rocks ♫
♫ I can type in the track and get album names back ♫
♫ While still in my PJs and socks ♫
♫ Sell us a song, you're the music man ♫
♫ My iPod's still got 10 gigs to go ♫
♫ Yes, we might prefer more compatibility ♫
♫ But Steve likes to run the whole show ♫
♫ I heard "Desperate Housewives" was great last night ♫
♫ But I had a bad piece of cod ♫
♫ As I threw up my meal, I thought, "It's no big deal" ♫
♫ I'll watch it tonight on my 'Pod ♫
♫ And now all of the networks are joining in ♫
♫ Two bucks a show without ads ♫
♫ It's a business those guys always wanted to try ♫
♫ But only Steve Jobs had the 'nads ♫
♫ They say we're young, don't watch TV ♫
♫ They say the Internet is all we see ♫
♫ But that's not true; they've got it wrong ♫
♫ See, all our shows are just two minutes long ♫
♫ Hey ♫
♫ I got YouTube ♫
And now, ladies and gentlemen,
a tribute to the Recording Industry Association of America --
the RIAA!
♫ Young man, you were surfin' along ♫
♫ And then, young man, you downloaded a song ♫
♫ And then, dumb man, copied it to your 'Pod ♫
♫ Then a phone call came to tell you ... ♫
♫ You've just been sued by the R-I-A-A ♫
♫ You've just been screwed by the R-I-A-A ♫
♫ Their attorneys say you committed a crime ♫
♫ And there'd better not be a next time ♫
♫ They've lost their minds at the R-I-A-A ♫
♫ Justice is blind at the R-I-A-A ♫
♫ You're depriving the bands ♫
♫ You are learning to steal ♫
♫ You can't do whatever you feel ♫
♫ CD sales have dropped every year ♫
♫ They're not greedy, they're just quaking with fear ♫
♫ Yes indeedy, what if their end is near ♫
♫ And we download all our music ♫
♫ Yeah, that would piss off the R-I-A-A ♫
♫ No plastic discs from the R-I-A-A ♫
♫ What a way to make friends ♫
♫ It's a plan that can't fail ♫
♫ All your customers off to jail ♫
♫ Who'll be next for the R-I-A-A? ♫
♫ What else is vexing the R-I-A-A? ♫
♫ Maybe whistling a tune ♫
♫ Maybe humming along ♫
♫ Maybe mocking 'em in a song ♫